shall we place wagers on elana's eta
since she is beholden to
outside forces
that sounds very ominous 10 minutes
10 minutes that's my optimistic like
very generous yeah exactly
see that's evil right that's definitely
evil lighting
that's evil lighting that that's that's
uh that's there's a surgical table below
you with like
yeah
you've got like bioshock uh
you know victims you're like making you
know little sisters or something on just
yeah every sentence by saying would you
kindly
there you go thank you better it's okay
always a little risky with the light
source coming from below though
regardless of color yeah i'm thinking
that i'm thinking i'm gonna adjust some
things
get a better fill is this the world's
brightest keyboard backlight
why is my internet connection unstable
yeah it's my keyboard my keyboard's just
glowing up i mean if you actually look
to see what you're typing you'll go
blind it's like a little hue pillar but
i'm thinking about getting and getting a
couple of them and
so i used to use a ring light anyway
this is this is this is not the content
people it is the a plus quality
are we glitching for you troy
yeah i just changed my
continuing in the path of
incredibly boring conversations i
uh just changed over my my
router my router your router i got my
router rooted
for some reason ever since i did it's
just it's been a little glitchy that
weird
it's it's strange because you've been uh
for me i've seen no hiccups
that's why that's the incoming when you
kind of yeah when you kind of frown like
you're losing the signal it's funny
because it looks like you're reacting to
absolutely nothing
or everything everything that's the side
of a good actor i'm reacting to nothing
yeah true
true that good it's like in friends
where joey's acting advice is if you
need to look serious try dividing
7025 or by 26. so he's like
timeless acting advice
that's a show
so here's uh
something that's uh
that i thought was fascinating and
there's probably nothing really to talk
about with it but i just was curious
your reactions it's a shame a lot isn't
here because i'm very fascinated by what
she'll say to this as well did you see
that the adult
who was a
newborn infant on the
famous nirvana cover is now suing them
for exploitation
no
uh really like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa two days ago this guy
he if i'm not mistaken and he not touch
the dollar did he not get to the dollar
yeah exactly and then that was his pay
he he redid the the photo i think he has
multiple times as an adult i think
there's like i think he's done like
proper photo shoots recreating this you
know this as an adult which is one of
those big red flags of like this is
smacks of total opportunism but here's
the thing that that really to me was so
fascinating is is it's really hard you
know me i'm always about what's the most
charitable
uh read on something you know never leap
to conclusions ever no matter how
damning something might look at the
outset there's there's always more to
the story there just always is but i
will admit one of the things that
immediately smacked of like oh my god
you got to be kidding me i just rolled
my eyes
you know reflexively
was that um apparently
um
you're like the idea of um
uh
like traditional legal precedents for
exploitation don't apply
um even the fact that there's nudity
uh
of it if an infant of a minor but not
even an infant but like practically a
newborn
most of the things that might flag that
as child pornography or something that
would potentially give you grounds for a
lawsuit don't really apply obviously
that would or i assume obviously i
didn't actually like check this as my
due diligence as if i'm a pi but we're
just scientists we're not lawyers yeah
exactly yeah yeah come on man
keep it within the bounds of reality my
uh assumption is
can you also mike if we can be further
on brand if you wouldn't mind when you
say my god jim
i'm a scientist
i i bet you've got a better you've got a
better impression than me my god jim i'm
a scientist not a lawyer there it is
um so yes presuming the
um
um
the legalities about presuming their uh
uh
parental consent and all those ducks
being in a row here was the twist on his
case
uh that i that i just thought you've got
to be kidding me like this seems like he
just kind of is hard up for cash
um and i hate you know to make judgments
but
he they the claim is that um
because contextually
the baby is reaching for a dollar which
bear in mind it was photoshopped
afterward that's not like in the it
wasn't a practical dollar in the shoot
like that's after the fact
um at least that's my understanding your
honor photoshop did not exist at the
time therefore well you know what i mean
opposing council is like well you didn't
say that though did you
well good thing
i'm sorry
[Music]
time traveling photographer high school
uh debate club uh situation here yeah
i'm sorry kyrie so um
he
his argument is because the baby is
reaching for a dollar
he was now uh a sex worker and
uh unduly compensated or something along
those lines and or it constitutes
exploitation of a minor by essentially
portraying them as a sex worker
something
in that vein and the crazy thing was
suing every member of the band
individually including um
courtney love is apparently the executor
of kurt cobain's estate i did not know
that i i guess that shouldn't be a
surprise but she's being sued as part of
it and then there was also someone else
in the suit where the article made point
of saying you know like as a side note
this person wasn't even in the band at
the time of the photo being taken so
it's odd they're being sued as well or
so it was like a producer who didn't
have to do with that album whatever it
was everyone but here was the other part
that was fascinating
the suit was all those people 150k a
peach a piece
and i thought
all this for if let's say he gets
everything he's asking for it will be
under a million dollars and maybe i'm
just jaded by our world of
every lawsuit is like for you know dr
evil 100 billion dollars um but i just
thought
as far as cash grabs go it's not the
most ambitious despite the
the
seemingly um
transparency
no this feels like it's for this doesn't
feel like if that's exactly what i was
going to say troy um
and it feels like i feel like he got
high with a friend of his that has a law
degree that just got out of the like
lost a lot of times okay here we go yeah
and he's like
you know what we should do
and it feels it smacks of someone going
my my whole the whole of my life i have
been defined by this one picture and now
that picture
no longer like you can't go to a bar and
go like hey uh you like naked babies
no oh [ __ ] that used to be my pickup
line wait a minute so how can i redefine
myself because there's no way no one's
going to go hey man are you the kid from
the nirvana there's like there's no way
right there's no way someone could
recognize him from that yeah so he has
to constantly be like i was the kid in
the pool and the nirvana
and he's taken photos to restage it
which is further bolstering your point
like so it's like
shame about it
yeah
this just feels like i'm trying to stay
relevant i'm trying to stay
you know
and and now there's there's a whole new
angle for me to take
by the legalities of it like like
whether there's actually a case like
it's one of those things where i wonder
i kind of okay do you guys watch like
the legal eagle videos have you ever
seen those
no
i'm kind of fascinated by what the
lawyer kind of take on this would be
apparently it all hinges on this sex
worker
um right but what is the loss there must
be a loss there must be an ability that
that loss must be attributed to the
person that you are suing and there must
be an ability to pay so two of those
three
you can you can find but what's the loss
mental anguish
that would be that i guess that would be
the argument that it's a crime in them
on the basis of portraying them as a sex
worker or something along those lines
i'm sure i'm sure i have the details of
this wrong yeah oh yeah if you're going
to look it up great i was going gonna
segue i was gonna say so what's who's
the best the most famous grown-up baby
any of you have met
i've got one
uh um that is a hell of a segue peter um
o'toole he's not a baby peter
the baby i would say a qualified thing
here is the baby version of them has to
be the most famous version of them
i would say i would say peter
billingsley is so who was which baby was
hit you christmas story so he's the kid
that's good
oh so he's the guy in um spider-man as
well then he's the
yeah he okay so he's assigned that
that that goes way way back because
uh he is he is in the the john favreau
um
click
so vince vaughn and peter billingsley
are like are like dear friends and they
they do a lot of stuff together and john
favreau as well
um i met him i didn't realize he was it
makes sense but he was um
he's a billings leader so like barbara
billingsley
and
from leave it to beaver
um
who else would there be i mean
trying to think
ashley johnson
child actor you know which i didn't know
someone pointed that out to me the other
day i'd never put ashley johnson
together with like childhood ashley
johnson i never made that link of those
those two people
mine is i know i met the the the babe
with the power what power the power of
voodoo power of hoodoo voodoo
i messed that up really
i did he's he works in um he works with
puppets still he's um he was like he was
like the kid of someone
who worked on that like uh and he was uh
he's now like yeah he worked on um i
visited this
the set of the the netflix dark crystal
show and he was yeah he's like he's
still there making puppets it's awesome
and he was introduced to me as the babe
with the power which is the power
exactly the power of voodoo
who do you do remind me oh
i i'm trying to think if i have a good
one to add to this i think the closest
i've got
it wasn't a baby though he was probably
uh 18.
my answer is how old were you troy when
you did the last of us
my
answer is he was one of the lost boys in
hook i think he was before the age of
10. oh
um no james mario uh who was later he
was in band of brothers uh
uh as an adult um but he was a young kid
um
and um he's done a bunch of other stuff
as well um
and
he's as far as as far as like a
noteworthy child actor
friend he's the only thing i can come up
with right now very lovely guy
i know i know the most famous baby that
i'm that
you've won
jesus christ
oh
i went to nyu concurrently with the
olsen twins they're pretty famous babies
i never i never crossed paths with them
but i'm the only one hanging on to that
there's only one olson
colbert's thing stephen copeland yeah
it's only one
oh yeah that's right man i missed that
show
you know what i miss i miss alana pierce
because otherwise it just becomes the
three of us
talking about babies talking about
[ __ ] that doesn't matter
about anything famous
especially when there's yeah you you got
to spin it off
by the way i am the host so i get to say
what happens
not a chance
i am in control i i don't know if
anybody saw this and i i mean the the
sam lake posted these pictures
of him wearing these shirts and he was
like hey by the way these shirts are for
sale i was like click oh
breaking [ __ ] cause i wanna
it's so weird i can't look at him and
not just like i can't pass him as a
human being i've seen like when i've
seen him like event stuff like my brain
just
checks out and goes it goes it's that's
max payne like it's see he's he turns
into a low polygon character he's
probably my brain just cannot
yeah it's just it's the coolest thing
ever i'm like you have
the most you are you are a character
you're not even and he's such a lovely
human being
but he's ju
and especially if you ever hear him
speak
it's like no
no no no
uh there's a story that that de niro
famously has always used the same person
in italian
to do his own dubbing and there was one
movie where de niro was like i want to
do my own dubbing i want to do my own
italian and so he did and the movie got
panned by italian critics they're like
who's the awful guy with a shitty voice
doing de niro because they had always
heard this thing so like seeing that
seeing that face and hearing a different
voice come out of it it's like that's
not what happened to you you're weird
don't do that
that whole subject is so
uh fascinating to me of the whole dubber
uh like because i never had as much
appreciation for that until i started
dating angela because
she you know
like growing up watching the simpsons it
was always in it was always dubbed in
spanish so once she reached an age in
life where she was going to uh comic con
type conventions and stuff you know in
the latin american world it was not
uncommon that those dubbers would be the
kinds of folks those actors doing the
the the recordings would be the people
there and so she's like she's like you
know that guy's famous because he dubs
homer but he also does these other shows
and these you know these
and like and the thing that's not just
fascinating about like she's for example
if if like it's on tv and and you see
she'll always recoil hearing the actual
voices because she's like that's not
what mr burns sounds like dude or
whatever like it's so ingrained in her
how they are
and so just uh but the funny thing is is
they make such fascinating choices uh
that are that are different from the
original it seems like there's a fair
amount of freedom
to
in some cases rewrite lines heavily to
make the gag work better in the new
language and things like that and um
like there's this there's this bit one
of my favorite things is to pull them up
on disney plus and cycle through because
there's the castilian
uh one as well
which is yeah which is totally different
i mean it's obviously both both in
spanish but not just the dialect and the
accents are different but the but the
lines change as well and there's this
great bit where they're at itchy and
scratchy land and there's like the
parents nightclub where they celebrate
new year's eve every night and so
they're like three two one the balls
fall and march says to this waiter
standing there like it must be so
wonderful to ring in the new year every
day and in english he goes please kill
me
and
and in uh and uh in the the sort of
latin american spanish he goes
i want to die in this super melodramatic
way
and uh and then i switch to the
castilian and he goes matami and it's
very like authoritative kill me and uh
it was like
i just i'm endlessly fascinated by these
little judgment calls that are made and
knowing that there's this whole
ecosystem of actors and
casting directors and we're so oblivious
i mean troy's been on the other side of
that right troy
work you do right i cut my teeth
yeah funimation like one of the first
gigs i ever got was was for a show uh
called detective conan
and it was about this kid that gets this
detective gets shrunk down to a kid and
i'm the one that did it to him um and
the person that cast me was a guy named
chris sabbat who is the gateway drug
into and for especially anime but voice
over specifically he still remains a
dear friend to this day and he taught me
so much and and he is famous for being
like if you ask who's the voice of
vegeta in in dragon ball z it's chris
sabbat so it's the same thing for the
whole western
world
aside from spanish and stuff because
there are dubs as well like you go to
japan and it's like no we've got you
know daisuke ono is the guy that i did a
lot of dubbing for
but to here we are considered like we
would do the convention circuit and
stuff because of the anime rules that we
did or the dubbing rules that we did and
it was it was a real treat to be able to
meet some of the people that had done um
like i got to meet the guy that did uh
the spanish dub of joel and he's this
very famous actor
um
and so and now it's to be pedro pascal
uh so that that guy's like i could have
done it
um so it's it's it's a it is an art form
it is a it is a defined skill set same
thing like you know spike spiegel from
cowboy bebop is is steve bloom you know
and that's the the authoritative voice
to us
but if you were in japan
completely different person and it's so
funny how there's just this mark of
delineation between
infamy and even like you know in the uk
uh so it's not just in america this
could be canada or depending upon you
know there's there's a couple of
different people i've done like
wolverine or whatever but um or
different animes and have used different
voices
some projects have like productions a
thousand different localized
iterations it seems like you know just
the the sheer like it's french canadian
french versus the french french factors
versus that like it's some of these
things it just it's just amazing to me
that
ask a technical question on it please
sorry
presumably with dubbing you're generally
you're voicing it's like it's like adr
you're voicing the cartoons in front of
you the anime's in front of you you've
got material is that right whereas
obviously that's usually that's not the
case on the other side if you're
originating a role does that change
anything about how you approach the
performance or how you do things
i think you're super boxed in aren't you
like you you have very narrow
offenses
i would say you're on rails right so the
the task that is put to you
is great all of your choices all of your
inflections everything you want to do do
that
within this amount of space so it's a
great acting challenge
because emotional making choices just
you are but you're you're definitely
just like i need you to do all and it's
taught me a lot because i would have a
tendency to always add words to a line
um and i still do it to this day and
there's a lot of actually as a writer
you know
how can you distill this down to its
quintessence so like in a performance if
the line is let's go
i would always have a tendency to be
like look come on let's let's just go
i'm like let us go hither
onto his own hill all of that that
you're doing i need you to take all of
that and i need you to just put that
into the the
because the reason why you're saying
look because you're trying to get their
attention let's just you have a bit of
hesitancy that's great instead of using
words
put all of that and distill it down to
let's go
and and can you do that so anime dubbing
anime really really helped teach me that
i still struggle against it because i
always want to add because the the
cheapest way for me to externalize my
choices is to do it in dialogue and
that's why hitchcock is such a powerful
maxim when all else fails use dialogue
you should be able to do all of that
without saying anything
you can say more by saying less
so
for sure and the way that they do it in
japan is different as well because
everyone like has
and maybe this has changed and and
someone could
clarify this word but as i understand it
there's a screen with the script and all
of the actors are there and when it is
your turn you step forward and then they
step forward and it's like all color
coded so it's very very uniform as
opposed to the way that we do it what
actors are brought in one by one
sometimes you get to hear just the
japanese version sometimes you get to
hear the rest of the cast to be able to
play off of so everyone's kind of in the
same space
but that's famously like where the speed
racer reads you got where a lot of
people trying to put a lot of and said
huh because you're having to especially
in japanese
there would be like a long tail on that
last word and you have to fill that flap
so that's the thing that there's so many
cultural different like languages are so
far from one to one corollaries to one
another especially if you're injecting
emotion and subtext and storytelling and
it's not just about literal information
transfer yeah
it's constructed
yeah it seems like it's a remark it's
actually a thing that
like
if when you you know the first time i
remember like taking a trip out of the
country fairly young and you turn on the
tv and you're like you're like in a
hotel and you turn it on and you see you
know
star wars and and it's all over dubbed
it it feels like you're looking at this
weird imposter like until you understand
anything about how the world works you
can realize when you see cable news in
america uh for the first time it's like
wow that's news okay are these people
for real
that's a separate problem
i remember watching duck tales in
germany when i was 13 years old and i
was like
wait a minute because i knew the episode
it's kind of like that that uh scene in
in home alone where they're they're
watching it's a wonderful life but it's
in french you know and you get to see
the super hammy performance by um
what's his name
oh my god it's just interesting because
we we are also not um
like in the us
generally
anime represents an exception to this
most of the time
we watch things with subtitles
um when we watch
non-english language like you think of
the most famous the most successful
films uh out from from from abroad in
the us i think are
still crouching tiger and amelie um
they're certainly two of the most
successful if not they were they they
broke their mind
what's the anime there was there was an
anime that came out like over christmas
that did real was it not demon
something no demon hunter
so there's there was a new anime that
came out there's gonna be it's gonna be
in the comments like recently
recently like over christmas that i
think just
it does
be able then i mean because i'm talking
about like 200 million
theatrical gross um i think i think
there was like genuinely there was one i
need to look it up independently how's
that even possible
uh because it was a niche audience
and i was there for like
six months because nothing else was
being played so there was there was a
weird kind of i i'm gonna have to look
this up yeah yeah i'm fascinated i i
hadn't heard about this
if you would love to see fat checker for
play watch listen email austin wintry at
oh why does this have to be my uh
my uh because of last week you were like
hey by the way did anybody's i haven't
seen anybody
i didn't see us it was demon slayer
demusler green screen
yeah
it had a worldwide gross of 500 million
holy um and i'm just gonna look up the
us for you
that is by the way that is uh pesos 500
million pesos that's right less
expensive australian dollars
yeah exactly
sort of less worthless
that's the kind of that's the kind of
thing when she's not here to defend
herself right go on they try to make fun
of us
getting better on this away all right us
gross 47 million
oh okay that's wildly under i think
where i got confused it still is the
highest grossing mma i think it's i
think was the highest grossing anime
that's where i went wrong so i think it
beats like spirited away and stuff like
that
wow studio
ghibli yeah that's interesting
point being
i'm sure that
if you went and saw theaters i would
think at least it is subtitled with the
original performances because that's
that tends to be the default position
for the way we watch things from outside
which is why it was doubly concerning
disconcerting as a kid to see
you know like beloved performances
um you know harris and ford and these
these like iconic just every last little
nuance scorched into my brain and then
you see another actor
and having to do what troy was just
describing where they're doing it in a
narrow confines of the timing and oh hey
look
i was off by 16 minutes was it troy troy
described it was uh fitting the flaps
right fitting yeah you got to fit it in
the flaps that's it that's a t-shirt fit
the flaps fit in the flaps
where the fourth beat
what
oh can't hear you
because uh yeah that's what we're here
for
what just happened
we're we're fitting it in the flaps why
are we doing this
context never be awesome
you only get jokes if you're on time
and we're doing it again so here's i
want people to understand we say this
with all earnest i
genuinely want someone to come up
with something clever nothing by the way
just in general you're gonna do
something shitty you're not gonna get
seen so don't worry about it
but if it's something clever that you
could do with the green square
of alana
the offer still stands we will match
the whatever ridiculous amount
but it would be better if the chair was
also green i feel like you can only do
so much [ __ ] up
you can do a lot man you can raise a
sponsorship that's what it is yeah
that's the trick oh sorry i tried i
literally just like
yeah he does have that that isn't bad i
feel bad that's kind of they were kind
they were like hey man your chair sucks
i was like it does they're like would
you like what it was like i would
they're like here you go do you want
anything
yeah because you're in between jobs they
had to give you a free chair falling
apart it's like guys i can't afford
these things yeah taking anything i can
get yeah
did you guys already talk about 12
minutes no we haven't talked we've been
waiting for you
yeah it's basically basically uh
the first 25 minutes of this is optional
and cuttable probably
great we did talk about the nirvana kid
uh suing nirvana 30 years later
um accusing them of uh making him into a
sex worker you missed that
wow i didn't know about that yeah it's
just this week uh but but no need to
drag you through what is probably a
ridiculously pointless
story let's get your thoughts on 12
minutes i saw you did a video i think
right about it i didn't see it so i
don't know did you already i did i did
not no
i have not done that i thought you did i
thought you uploaded something or were
you it was you i tried to stream it and
failed so it was like
maybe six minutes of a stream so in
other words
sounds like an edie raquel song by
sometimes i open at exactly the right
moment i literally one time refreshed
youtube right now who uploaded something
because it was it showed up as zero
views on one of your uh videos and i
thought that that that i i i hated you i
hit a target that is one millisecond
i love doing that but i love doing it
like a week later uh i love you just
being the clueless guy
shows up first you are the 7 000th
comment uh did you know about that
website where you can
intentionally find videos on youtube
that have no views it'll just shuffle
through zero view videos on youtube of
course somebody has made the link
i saw this guy reviewing a hammer that
was he was actually fantastic look not a
huge market for hammer reviews
you kind of buy a hammer i think
was it a good hammer or bad habit it
seemed like a good hammer you seem to
like the hammer but i feel like you kind
of buy it and you know what you're
getting you've got it you've got to be
more controversial in the hammer review
business because you're going to go troy
he was much more enthusiastic troy's
voice right now makes me feel like i
have another window open
like hey i feel like
lot of you've written everybody
asking me to review this hammer so i'm
gonna do it it's this first video with
zero views no one has asked you to do
any of these things yeah you're talking
about hey everybody just wanna uh send a
new video about um this is the hammer
that i was talking about
i mean don't you even don't you doesn't
it show it as a view if you like double
check your own video to make sure it's
uploaded correctly or something yeah
you look at it yourself you'll get a
view yeah the hell happened to troy
he's transcended he's now on
he was raptured hey look turns out he
got a really good idea he was like you
know what i'm gonna go make this hammer
content [ __ ] this
you see that completely respect yeah and
just wait a way to immediately uh should
i let him back in i have i have admin
powers
you know oh there he is what happened
here's the video of the uh thanks
everybody for tuning in for another
video of mine i want to thank
special shout out
i'd watch that too though i like this
game 69 of uh appreciate you happy
birthday
make sure to smash that like and
subscribe button
i feel
that but he doesn't edit any of that out
either this this all here
i actually had one of these once that
i got tagged
like i went
i think someone sent it to me or maybe i
got a google alert somehow i got a video
i like the real-time parallels
this is the level of dedication that
troy will go for somebody did any voice
act this is this is this is this is the
thing is you see a lot of live-action
actors who can't do the voice acting
it's true he's a voice actor who can do
the live action hey everybody double
dragon in asking me to talk about what
the the sharpies that i use i use
sharpie i did see that in the comments
actually one time
[Laughter]
can you just hold position in this
blurry too close yeah well uh while troy
protects you
uh i wanted to say uh austin
congratulations on
aliens oh thanks i thoroughly enjoyed
being your uh tech support um during
your stream well you were completely
useless but um that's not true i
connected you i brought i i got the
creative director to join the stream and
he also was useless
that's true
that's always a good sign too it was
good works guys
it was happening
okay
i thought the music was very good we
kept uh making who did
um
to
i don't think they were actually bongos
but it seemed like they were aggressive
when you accuse him of
so we were making a lot of references to
austin wintery furiously bongoing in a
bedroom uh while we're fighting
big xenomorphs most people don't know
but he actually called in a favor
and got matthew mcconaughey to play
those bongos and he was high and naked
when he did hey everybody
yeah
but yeah i thoroughly enjoyed it austin
i thought you did a great job i was like
this yep because music is good
and it is aliens
it was a blast it is aliens uh it was
really fun and apparently it's been
doing really well because steam made it
their giant banner splash image today uh
just like
the creative directors woke up and was
like holy [ __ ] we are apparently
um a giant baby
we are we are we are steam right now um
yeah
not the starboard bow is a giant banner
splash image yeah
i don't think you're allowed to do that
if we're talking about aliens though you
feel like you're kind of mixing your
your streams yeah that's true that's
right in the trap right
now
that's somehow better though
i think it's somehow better to go
ghostbusters with aliens but go
ghostbusters yeah anyway it's been it
was it was a blast you know that that
game um could very easily have not
existed because disney bought fox
right smack in the middle of development
and a lot of studios don't survive
corporate hand
changing uh in that way
um and um but everybody
everybody who because the company got
bought and sold several times and
everybody
that
bought it usually was it was you know
they were they were basically like this
is so cool it's not really
for our portfolio but we don't want to
see it die so how can we help you
survive you know it's like it seemed
like there was a lot of good will
to not just treat it as like
ah that you know i bought i went to a
garage sale i bought a box because i
want this one thing in the box and i'll
just throw the rest away or
you know
give it to the the
goodwill or something it was like it was
like
this i don't want but i want it to exist
and it really could have easily not it
could have easily gone another way i
think i don't obviously that's awesome
specifics of all that i just remember
getting multiple multiple meetings like
an inordinate number of meetings
throughout the project of
so we were bought again
at the start of the meeting like holy
[ __ ]
um but uh always always a positive uh
attitude and it
never yeah they're such a lovely team
i'm so
i'm so stoked for them because it's not
a huge developer cold iron you know i
think they're like maybe 30 40 people
um and they were given real
latitude by fox to just like run with it
and you can incorporate
you know
current like prometheus covenant type
lore and visuals and obviously all the
old stuff you can invent new
xenos you can you know really like go
nuts uh with where you want to take it
which was really
you know
they and yeah
they had a lot of yeah
for context for anyone listening who's
not aware it's called aliens fire team
elite
came out
wednesday tuesday tuesday um and is a
left for dead like is how i would
describe it it's very much like left the
dead it has like a worldwide world
yeah yeah um has a hub world that is a
bit more elaborate than actually either
of those games i don't think world war z
has a hub well though it does do
loadouts um oh yeah you liked the uh the
kind of
the the you kept hearing the music in
the hub in the hangar yeah
it was like this like it's like there
were two guys listening to some kind of
jukebox or something but i couldn't
locate the source of it and i didn't
know what it was that was that was a
that was one of my ideas that i pitched
to the developer originally the idea was
can it be coming out the back of the
drop ship of like the it's like the
pilots uh
you know like pump up uh like i'm about
to go you know into hell and so i so i
said i want to do a very kind of
nine inch nailsy sort of grungy thing
for the hanger and the cool thing was
um
i at the end of the pathless i did this
composer competition where i put out a
stem of the music and basically said
anybody can make anything they want out
of this and i'm gonna poke through the
the ones i like and find a way to
collaborate and there was this one
young girl who who did this really kind
of interesting remix of it and so
when i was finishing aliens i sent her
that piece that i'd written for the
hanger and i said um
take this and do anything you want to it
like completely turn it into a new piece
of music so if in the hangar
um it alternate it goes back and forth
between the two
versions cool
and yeah she did an awesome job um very
cool she's very young she's like
i think she's still in university
um and uh so i was like
man i wish i had had anything
approaching these chops when i was that
age
uh i didn't know anything especially
about production but
anyway so in the in the in the
approximately 12 minutes that i have
before i have to leave
seven
yeah oh right true
i love it when troy just yells a number
you know it really spices up it's a [ __ ]
it's no one yells a number like troy
does it's true seven yeah
any minute now um well uh the second
congrats to the show is mike
you got an xbox congratulations
tweet about your game 2001 yeah i'm very
excited and we forced you to immediately
play a game that i was so i'm sure the
three of you would hate
you were correct but you you did yeah i
bought xbox specifically because you
told me to that's genuinely why i bought
it you spent 500 just to buy 12 minutes
money bags mike
i do realize the game is longer than 12
minutes right did you give it did you
give it only 12 minutes i i went i wear
14 for the credits 14. i actually
completed it in like the first loop it's
like instantaneous
champion
didn't even have to spoil his drug and
torture your wife
that's great that's great choice i think
everybody should play this game
i actually completely agree i agree also
yeah i think everybody should play this
game so that you are you have an
informed opinion and i love dissent and
i love discourse i love people being
able to say here is why i really enjoyed
this game
um i think that uh what to me it's more
of a fascinating conversation about the
development of a game and the process by
which
an independent developer works with
an independent publisher
and the relationship because i want to
know the story of how that happened
uh contextually as i understand it that
game was in development for
years a long time it's basically one guy
one person
i want to know what those conversations
were like i want to know
um
when and why the choice to have
willem dafoe
james mcavoy and daisy ridley that i
literally texted a friend and i was like
dude is this you in 12 minutes he goes
what and i thought that
i just didn't understand i kept waiting
for james mcavoy to show up i'm like if
you get james mcavoy purely as a voice
then get james mcavoy like i want to
hear just like i heard willem dafoe
so i don't know natural accent even yeah
even daisy ridley obviously i did not i
did not i was 100 i had the same thing i
was not convinced that was her i because
sometimes you can hear the accent come
in when they shout both of them like you
can always
yeah that's that's you'll always the the
shouting will betray you and that that
goes for any kind of character
affectation or anything you could i can
identify people that i know i'm like
that's yuri that's nolan i can tell
people by their screams
um
what do you do tonight troy
that's their scream
yeah
you can also you can also identify them
by their slow labored wheezing
that's why that's what my friends sound
like
quality yeah i will say this and this is
in the interest of or in the spirit of
the conversation that we've had for
several weeks now talking about
criticism
um i believe that if you want to make a
game and you want you want to do
anything if you want to make anything if
i want to make anything and make it just
for myself i can totally do that but the
second that i put it out to the world
you are
understanding and you are agreeing to a
social contract that says people are
going to tell me what they think of this
thing that's the deal so if you want to
put it out you have to understand that
you are signing up for people to tell
you what you feel you don't have to
receive it especially if you're asking
for money for it especially if you're
asking for money so
in the spirit of that i
i would say
that
your talent better not be
the highest single line item on your
budget
if that is true
that would have been the case to be
honest yeah i don't know that it was a
cheap game
i don't think like
knowing knowing like the costs of those
kind of actors having worked with that
with some babies sure
having a pretty good sense of it i would
expect i actually think the
quietly probably one of the more
expensive aspects of the game was
probably the animation
uh which is a shame really
it was it was mocap which i thought was
very interesting when it's top down
i don't understand that and especially
when those look like and i know that
studio i know rouge mocap i know what
they're capable of
i don't understand how they how they
used mocap it didn't look mobile at all
that is a half hour conversation uh
people who've played john wick hex will
know that our animation hasn't always
been stellar and there's some very
tricky problems they're trying to solve
they're similar to some of the ones
we've tried to solve in the past and i
can see the same challenges so that's a
we should have that conversation
something's either perspective issue i
suspect it's a combination of
perspective and also just use case like
you've got there's a lot more you can
hide the perspective definitely like
reveals a lot of problems but also just
in terms of
non-player directed movement is it's
tricky there's lots of things it'll be
it will have a cat chat about that
because that is technically fascinating
i think there are things that are also
going to look awkward automatically when
you are interrupting other people all
the time like the the other two
you constantly interrupt when they are
mid animation or they interrupt you and
thus it automatically looks awkward it's
a little bit like um kind of if people
remember like the original odd world
where like that those animations would
play out in a very
like basically you had to watch the
entire animation like it wasn't reactive
in the way that most games are the
original odd world it's it's that same
kind of problem but it's also just in
terms of things like foot planting which
remains just an incredibly tricky thing
to do especially
um in small spaces and without much
movement you can hide a lot when
everyone's like running really fast or
there's lots of motion in the scene
otherwise
showing it's it's the age old thing the
most expensive and difficult thing to do
in video games is the mundane and
everyday
taking your jacket off yeah everything
is like everything's nightmare if you
want to make an alien world and run
across it 60 miles per hour that's so
cheap compared to making someone get a
cup of tea take a shower
yeah yeah right
i uh i think um i think to to the spirit
of troy's point though i i definitely it
feels like
had it been
three actors working at scale and
recording 10 times more lines
um
it probably would have improved the game
since you're
setting aside willem dafoe who was very
willem dafoey and that was enjoyable
when he spoke
get in here
yeah i i i just picture him like they
yell cut he's like how was that one like
he's just he just is that guy and uh
i um
so it's like if you're not
other than obviously the marketing boost
that you get to having famous actors
obviously there's no disputing there's
no disputing that um and it probably is
there though do you well i don't know if
it translates to sales but i know that
this game did i think in this instance
when it was like oh annapurna daisy
ridley willem defoe i i think people
were like wow what and on a game that's
not a big giant
you know horizon zero dawn massive
scale or like you know not that there's
like famous movie stars indie darling
art house but like yeah a game that's
solely one camera angle with an asterisk
from above you know like
that that that's not a place you expect
to find it so it did raise eyebrows but
setting all this aside my point is that
i was hurrying to make is that um
um
there were so many times where i played
it where i i have deep admiration for
the technical challenge of what uh the
design of the of the of the kind of
insane spiderweb nature of the
of the narrative flow and i really i
love the aspiration of this game so much
this sort of roguelike point-and-click
adventure against fighting against a
real-time clock is a fascinating blend
of mechanics that and and all that works
great and i don't have any problem with
you know i saw a lot of people were very
kind of upset by where the story goes
and i'll never be the guy to complain
about where someone wants to take their
story i don't necessarily like it but
i'm not like horrified by it because
there's no i feel like i saw i thought
it was a little bit silly more so than i
was angry at it yeah not a single
trigger warning
not a single trigger warning more
contrived than than but but so the
point being that there were so many
times where i could feel it funnel back
to a line that i that i knew like an
exact read of a line that i'd heard a
thousand times but coming from a
different line than the last time and
that to me when i hear that it strikes
me as we had a real finite amount of
takes that we basically
can get because
dollars are chipping away fairly at a
fairly high clip whereas if we had
you know three scale performers where we
could get a thousand versions of those
lines
uh it would because the whole game
basically is a dialogue like why not
make that the
the the depth of your investment i say
that i'm
just missing all the puzzle design and
whatnot not trying to be disciplined i
don't i don't think it's got anything to
do with the actors i really don't like i
think there's
fundamental kind of design and design
and direction or my complaints yeah it's
not and writing like it's not
i don't think there was a secret bigger
script that could have been done that
would have solved the issues i think
there is fundamental kind of design as
someone who's like designed a few kind
of dialogue adventure games now
there are there are things in there that
are weirdly constructed in a way that
feels just under baked in a lot of ways
or kind of first draft it feels like a
first first draft or a first game kind
of
and then to be clear like massive
respect to any dev team who makes a game
all of those caveats like i'm not one to
be like overly harsh on stuff but it
does feel
yeah just from a narrative design point
of view it just feels like there's
there's a lot of uh
things that could be tweaked i think as
well the console version at least the
version i played was really buggy which
kind of instantly kind of put me on the
back foot like it's like with little
like ui stuff that was surprising to see
kind of not working could you not play
it on steam
segment could you not play it on steam
no i played it on my new xbox troll i
know that but i was like i also played
it on xbox and didn't have any issues
but i played it so i had some case by
case space i had some stuff with like
the menu so like for example like the
inventory if you press the down button
to bring up the inventory if you hold
that button down it kind of keeps flip
flipping back and forth i actually did
have have the cursor get stuck on items
occasionally actually yeah that's just a
few buttons it's just going accessing
that inventory so to me the timeline
broke
the
when you are
the thing you're beating the clock
trying to raise the clock is solving the
mystery
um but it's also
the
the impetus for doing that is out of
protection right
um but they consistently
use that because it's such a system and
such a mechanic
then it loses all value
well also you get ahead of it at least i
don't know if this was the case for you
guys but like story wise it there's a
certain point i think about halfway
through
where
i knew the truth minutes like i just
six minutes
i'd figured out like the twists that
were coming up so it was more a case of
i was trying to work out how to make the
game get to the thing i knew had to
happen next rather than kind of
discovering through that the fast
forward that's intentional
yeah like the fast forward button was an
interesting feature but to me
the aesthetic of it
all of a sudden i extrapolated it was
like oh what if this is something now
that we're top down we're fast forward
it's like it's i'm watching footage of
this so is that how
and it never did that it was like oh no
we just needed it we just needed a fast
forward button because we knew that you
were gonna get bored it was like that's
you compensating for me understanding
that this is going to be bad design as
opposed to
create a system that says let me stop
you there like
actualize that i i i
don't disagree like i played through it
twice and i think i got every single
ending and there are like a few um
super interesting ones you wouldn't
expect like there's one where if you go
into the room and you just don't move at
all you just never move it plays out
differently
um because i was just playing with that
kind of stuff because yeah
there's a remarkable amount of content
no but it is also like
surprisingly can be quite different like
if i was like i wonder what happens if i
do this and i would say 50 of the time
something actually different and
satisfying happened in the other 50 time
i did get the same lines of dialogue
over and over again but in terms of the
fast forward button a i kept
accidentally doing it too soon and then
my wife kept calling me rude because i
clicked away from her so she thought i
didn't want to kiss her every day right
that just kept happening yeah but b i i
don't think it's like it's trying to
prevent you from getting bored when
i feel like the
the narrative meets design there is
actually very good in that if you're
stuck in a time loop you are going to
get frustrated
well i also think i think the biggest
problem or the one that maybe troy's
reacting to there is that for a time
loop if you look at most time loop
fiction
you've got in the time loop even like
obviously in groundhog day you're not
watching a real day play out in real
time but you are seeing a sequence of
like 20 or 30 repeated events and you're
seeing a character navigate those
repeated you know he steps in the puddle
he does this he does that
in this game there's really only
one consistent like unavoidable event
which is the the dock on the door
right yeah and therefore mechanically
you're kind of there's a really
interesting constraint to that that like
essentially you spend a lot of the game
waiting for the door right like that's
and it's not i think that's one of the
things that immediately jumps out to me
or something like i'd love to see kind
of explored in a sequel or someone
taking this idea and going further like
looking to the two things i think make
something like groundhog day or source
code or whatever interesting which is
one like i said multiple events that are
happening outside your control so you're
kind of working out how to navigate a
three-dimensional kind of time or a
two-dimensional timeline rather than
just a one-event timeline which we've
got here
the other thing i really want um i
wanted to see and i think would have
gone a long way i've heard actually
other games have come out with time
loops recently have done this is the
idea of grocking so the idea of like in
real life you don't think about the
process of walking to your local store
and buying something you just you
autopilot essentially once you know how
to do something and you see this all the
time in time-loop movies of like they'll
start to montage things you know yeah so
to show you the kind of that being
fast-forwarded how many times did you
lay the table for dinner in that game
before you realized navigating and also
doesn't have to do it either which is
why i realized no you don't have to
yeah um i have to run anywhere i'm sorry
i could just automate that oh sorry yes
yeah i have to i have to go do a panel
and they're they're i'm holding them at
bay only so much longer um so gotta run
you're in a live event right now and
you're you're keeping an audience late i
i mean it goes live in
12 minutes ironically uh wow there you
go
yeah so if someone's going to knock on
your door in six minutes but nothing
else is going to happen yeah i just have
to call his daughter and uh yeah
we should have a longer chat about this
i really yeah yeah mike you really you
really i would love
i would you've exposed that some of my
guesses about why certain things were
the way they were being potentially
wrong really interests me so let's
definitely talk about this again next
week sorry oh yeah to have to uh
smoke up let's do it no worries but
since you were the host austin or alana
do you want to do it
everyone thanks for watching please
see you next week bye
we nailed it